here's a pubmed ncbi um and like this is
a medical journal
so i mean
you know what cuz
okay you know what just hold it up for
me
0.0018 almost 100 times lower than
fossil sterling estimate of 1.7 so it is
because they're can you hold that up for
the camera
welcome back to part two
of our change my mind installment
specifically on the topic that
biological males should not compete in
women's sports well at least
that's what
it was supposed to be
see yesterday i sat down and spoke with
isaac and although we disagreed we had a
productive almost hour-long discussion
but in case you've forgotten civility
wasn't exactly on
everybody's mind that day
and these are adults acting this way in
college
at unt the harvard of denton county no
less and i had to wonder why would
college students ever
think it's acceptable to behave this way
enter one of their self-described
mentors steven monticello all right so
it's okay we're we're comfortable with
our masculinity more you can move in the
better sorry all right so you can
actually oh you got the mic on the desk
oh there you go here i'll play that your
name is steven that's right stephen
monticelli is a contributing writer at
rolling stone and the daily beast where
he specializes in leftist talking points
and attacking college students he's even
made an appearance on cnn's new day
that's right also this noted inspector
gadget impressionist who cosplays as
indiana jones enthusiasts had clearly
been waiting for change my mind to come
to unt the harvard of denton county for
quite some time and he just couldn't
hide his enthusiasm all right good you
spelled the phrave same way very nice
fewer letters means a cooler name uh
last name monticelli i'll spell it for
you okay m-o-n-a-c-e-l-l-i
so
german
italian
boy missed all of that one
missed it by that much just a little bit
but you know both of those countries
have a certain history for a certain
type of politics but we're not here to
talk about that today yeah no i know
i don't know how i got that one wrong
it's almost like uh
almost like i wasn't even trying oh look
the sense of humor mobile it's not
stopping here so steve steven steve how
do you prefer steven
by the way i like this uh this jacket
come on thanks yeah go for it is it a
raincoat or is it it's just like a
cotton jacket it's been like i guess
surplus okay military outfit works um so
stephen i don't know how familiar you
are at all with what we do with this uh
kind of installment is but it's
basically a way where we can hopefully
rationalize our positions on
controversial topics a lot of the times
people can have somewhat rational
conversations on topics that maybe don't
evoke an emotional response and then it
all goes out the window as you've seen
here on college campuses with dancing
yoda and people throwing milkshakes and
screaming and all these kinds of things
which we generally like to avoid now
spoiler alert this is about to go
sideways
very quickly so today's topic is one
obviously we planned for a while but now
it's in the news because of leah thomas
i don't believe that biological
males should be allowed to compete
with women
biological females in women's sports
if you disagree with me
more than happy to hear your case and
sure you changed my mind so i guess
before we get into it what is your
definition of the term biological female
is that
something that would include people who
are assigned female at birth that were
born intersex
so this is interesting that you're
bringing up this point intersect you're
talking about the point zero one percent
of that it's about 1.5 1.7 because there
are surgeries that are done to babies
when they're babies when they're born
and then they assign them a gender so
let me address two different points sure
first off what i'm saying with
biological males and females is the
overwhelming majority of people uh of
course across the globe since the
beginning of time who are born
as a male or as a female you can go not
only by chromosomes but secondary so
like if there's are there 100 people
here let me finish
uh and then i'll address your second
point okay
is that fair sure
so doctors for example fill out male or
female now we're talking about sex right
we're not talking about identified
gender i'm assuming that you would
agree
with the biological term and gender is
there's a definition of social
difference i understand that's how
gender theory is presented certainly in
gender studies on college campuses sure
with intersex it's about
point zero one percent of the population
and the vast majority of them once again
it's the vast majority of them don't
require any kind of a sex change that's
actually not an accurate
accuracy available right now it's
1.5 1.5 of the population is not
intersex well they're born that way and
then a very small percentage of them
are improperly assigned with a primary
sex at birth they usually have primary
sexual characteristics okay so primary
sexual characteristics and very few have
to end up going with some kind of a sex
change operation later in life because
it's often done when their children are
in their babies right or they're
assigned male female at birth so yeah i
guess that's what i'm trying to get it
are you talking about what i'm doing
right so we separate that intersects
okay so let's say we apologize
no i'm saying let's say we allow
intersex to compete in the division they
choose how do you how do you prove that
there and how do you even get to that
question of
are you are you not are you asking then
that there has to be a box that people
have to tick that they were interested
i'm confused by you presenting the
argument here because you asked me about
intersex yeah yeah so what i'm trying to
say is there are edge cases here that i
don't think that your presentation
actually encompasses and i just
encompassed it
so if people
are allowed so that someone who is born
with both female and male sex
characteristics there you go now you've
got it yeah so yeah and then there are
surgeries that are done
but someone would have to ask them that
yes so are you proposing that people are
asked what i'm saying is if someone is
intersex let's allow that to be an
exception let's say that some of those
in any division they want to how do we
know they would have to declare if
they're intersex so your absolutely
submitted they would obviously be
examined by a doctor just as the women
are in women's sports and men are in
men's sports just so they have to submit
to not only blood sampling for drug
tests hair follicle sampling often nail
strippings right we both know that
physicals are conducted in all sports to
separate for what
sex
right to separate for weight
to separate for
when i was playing sports when i was a
kid no one ever inspected my genitals
really no you never to turn your head in
cough well that wasn't for doing sports
that's called a physical that's a
medical thing that was separate from
being able to do sports yeah so you know
how to do a full medical
i mean so you must not have played
sports at a high level because
everyone has to pass a medical yeah so
you do realize that at division one
sports you would have to pass a medical
so the medical would be a description of
your genitals would that would include
it it would include a written
description and a verbal description yes
really
medical examination yeah would include
the description of your vitals okay of
your health okay your health parameters
so i guess now that we've gone through
that what is we haven't gone through
that what is the reason that you're you
haven't gone through that yeah so if
you're concerned if you're less
concerned about intersex people then why
are you so concerned about transgender
people
again i was answering your question you
asked about it they both they both get
they both get surgery sometimes they
both need hormone treatment what what's
your what's your position against if
you're okay with one why are you not
okay
well here's exactly why first off you're
taking an extreme example to make a
point misrepresenting those statistics
that's not one point five percent of the
population in the
you won't find a single position in the
country
well one according to experts on 1.7 of
the population is born with intersex
trade pause a second
let's analyze his googling techniques
a two-click google search it's almost as
if he had the whole thing planned out
poorly 1.7 of the population is born
with intersex traits that's from
amnesty.org i mean
yeah i mean i can just like keep keep i
can go to from amnesty i mean it's from
there's there's wikipedia there's
there's people yeah i'm just in
wikipedia okay there's uh here's a
pubmed ncbi um and like this is a
medical journal so i mean
let me actually
let you know what because
okay you know what just hold it up for
me anyone that hold it up for nights
because you just brought up pubmed and
it didn't reflect what you just
reflected on so abstract
zero point zero zero one eight percent
almost one hundred times lower than
fossil sterling estimate of one point
seven so it is because they're can you
hold that up for the camera
can you hold it up to the camera
consistent can you hold that up to the
camera yeah so let's see
let's see can you hold it up to the
camera there's a debate about this which
is what we're having pause now if you
notice the shift and i mean uh increase
in my enthusiasm it's because i was
intensely familiar with the pubmed paper
he was attempting to cite and by sight i
mean blatantly misrepresent and by
blatantly misrepresent i mean lie about
and this is the real value of change my
mind in the conversations being included
in their full context unedited it's one
thing to be able to lie about numbers to
unsuspecting students in order to score
political points it's another to face
accountability in real time so let's
rewind
and zoom in and enhance on his screen
unfortunately the tech isn't good enough
to get a crystal clear picture but
here's the actual pubmed article
abstract if the term intersex is to
retain any meaning the term should be
restricted to those conditions in which
chromosomal sex is inconsistent with
phenotypic sex or in which the phenotype
is not classifiable as either male or
female applying this more precise
definition the true prevalence of
intersex is seen to be about
0.018 percent almost 100 times lower
than the fausto sterling estimate of 1.7
can you hold it up to the camera there's
a debate about this which is what we're
having yeah you can no wonder the social
justice warrior slash handler of curious
george shoved his phone back in his
pocket faster than a crack pipe at the
bordello of biden yeah you can google it
you can get different the only hold on a
second let me finish here because
you just brought up amnesty.org and
wikipedia sure the only legitimate
medical publication that you brought up
said exactly what i said what number did
i give you so what's gonna give you so
then let's like put it in one number if
there are a hundred people here or a
thousand people here if there are a
hundred people here or there are a
thousand people here there's still going
to be at least one person
look if you're not still going to be at
least if church doesn't matter to you
this isn't going to be productive i'm
actually giving the numbers what number
did i give to you so you gave me point
one percent point zero one percent point
zero percent what is that number from
pubmed say let's see it says point uh
point zero eight point zero one eight
percent point
zero
one eight percent yeah yeah that's the
number i gave you so let's see what
pubmed just said that is pubmed you just
showed the pubmed yeah i'm just gonna
pull it now you're going back to
amnesty.org you're going to wikipedia so
my point is look
you sit here and you spout numbers that
are inaccurate when you go to one
legitimate medical journal it says that
it's actually a thousand times lower so
do we want to have a conversation about
the topic at hand or do you want to keep
embarrassing yourself with wrong members
so
if you're going to accept
that there are
people in this world no matter how rare
that you think that they are that you're
going to allow to participate in sports
no matter how rare your own source is no
no no no no no matter how rare that
there are in existence it doesn't matter
what you think or what i think they
exist the numbers are the numbers do you
believe that they exist
of course i believe it so zero eight
percent according so there are people so
there are people in this state in this
city
who would fit that categorization and
just because they're a small number of
them
you're going to just kind of disregard
what number of them require some kind of
sex change what number of them require
why is that so threatening to you it's
not threatening to me it seems like it
is well what's what's bothering to me is
your dishonesty
so i'll put a red hair number i'll grant
your number and my argument is still the
same so what's the number of people
there who are not accurately defined at
birth by their primary and secondary
sexual characteristics so once again why
is point two percent of point zero one
point eight percent of the population so
because now
people
that's
are competing in sports that are
transgender what's that number of the
population what's that percentage number
of transgender people percentage of the
total population yeah and that's how it
supports as far as the categories that
they enter they end up winning about 66
for example in track upwards of 90
percent in strength sports like power
lifting and olympic lift
that's significant
so even though they make up one percent
of the population when they enter into
female sports they overwhelmingly tend
to dominate and this is a very small
sample size so my question to you is
what do we do
because you're supposed to sit here are
we going to start talking about uh
genetics as it relates to people winning
sports is that what you want to do
is you're out that way your sports are
separated by biology yes
i mean what's the point of sports
to win
it don't matter if you win by an inch or
a mile that's right winning's winning
why is that funny uh it just tells me a
lot about who you are the point of
sports is not to win i think a lot of
people think there's more than one point
to sports i mean so much of sports is
like people getting sweaty and like
rubbing around with each other what's
the point to winning an olympic medal
uh i don't know i mean why do we have
the olympics
to identify who the best is at sport
what is the historical reason why we
have the olympics do you mean you want
to go back to pancration
i mean do we want to talk about no like
the the modern
renovation of it
okay so
fascist politics you know all that kind
of stuff so you believe that people are
competing for example in swimming
decathlon biathlon
no i think it's politics i think that
the overarching mindset that sports is
about you know declaring dominance and
that there's some sort of
actual value in like this idea of
international representation of
dominance and sports
when did you did you ever have fun in
your life like you ever have fun playing
sports
about representing international
dominance no but i'm saying it's like
you said it's all about winning so what
is the point of sports what is the point
i think i think sports is a lot about
having fun and you know making
relationships with people and do you
think
to make the olympic meddling platform i
think that's fun go on facebook is it
fun no sir no no absolutely not zero fun
sir all right
i mean it must provide a sense of
accomplishment
why presence of joy because they worked
hard to get there and the joy and
accomplishment comes from what
working hard to get there i guess
wouldn't you do going to great lengths
to avoid the term winning amount i mean
hey if you get second place and you're
spoiled brat about it i think a lot of
people would think you're kind of lame
do you think that the uh olympic silver
medalist who took second place to leah
thomas who wouldn't be ranked top 500 in
the male division as being a spoiled
brat what is your solution would you
want to create an entirely separate
category for transgender people in
sports if you want to we can otherwise
that's not what i want to i'm asking
what you want yeah i think biological
males should compete with biological
male 1 what it would i'm asking
specifically about transgender and
intersex people now what do you where do
you think they should communicate well
let's separate transgender intersex
because intersex people don't want to be
lumped in with transgenders i mean who
are you to speak for them
are you telling me something about
yourself i'm letting them speak for them
but i'm sure you'll find statistics that
will prove you wrong and bolster what
i'm discussing right now intersex people
don't want to be lumped in with
transgender individuals because there is
a biological issue there's not a
biological issue with transgender
individuals it is a societal issue
is it a biological issue that you would
never make a basketball team because you
can't
[Music]
jump i can't jump yeah why are you
making that presumption
i'm just kind of following this logic to
where you might conclude
no i'm asking are you
you're asking am i racist yeah what i'm
saying is if you're so obsessed with
certain types of people winning certain
types of categories as if there's some
sort of biological yeah
so you're an essential statement of my
imagination you're an essentialist oh
well let's throw that tomorrow what do
you mean that i'm an essentialist that i
believe biological males should compete
against biological males well i mean you
just talk about biological males and
females so much that it essentializes
gender into a binary that doesn't
include all these people that we've just
been talking about and sex into a binary
and sex yeah you said gender and sex
yeah i didn't mention gender i mentioned
sex well i'm talking about both yeah you
i would say well then let's just focus
on sex you are creating a an essential
extraordinary compe
yeah yeah okay so if you are saying that
it is not binary sex then you are
suggesting there should be a third
division
not necessarily what's your solution
i'm saying we should maybe uh stop
taking sports so damn seriously and let
people compete and create structures for
competing that
aren't so damn politicized how about
that
how about new
okay great so women should just shut up
and take it um
they're taking it too seriously women
are taking action that's what i think
you're taking it too seriously no i'm
saying women out there are taking it too
seriously talk to a woman there's plenty
of women here talk to a woman yeah i
have and i've spoken with many what does
she say there's also what did they say
they of course don't want biological
males to compete in women all right so
i'm gonna give up my seat now is there a
woman who would like to speak to him
because it's funny he should ask
because we just so happen to have talked
to a female athlete one of leah thomas's
teammates
peers if you will at u-pen to be exact
and here's what she had to say
that guy moniceli seems to be uneducated
i would say that the way the rules are
set up right now straight up deny women
from equal educational opportunities in
sport and discriminate against women by
not recognizing the physical differences
between men and women and women
shouldn't be forced to take a back seat
in their own sport
female athletes
all right cool hey it's been nice steve
thank you take care i appreciate it um
i don't know so no solution no dog in
the fight just wrong sources
uh another conversation's been very good
i'd say i'd say
have fun making it your career to go
talk to college students who don't want
to talk to you don't be so your whole
life
now given what's transpired one might
think that mr monticelli would take the
l
and never speak of this embarrassing
performance again
but that's not what insane people do
instead he took to twitter to declare
victory and attempt to dox our car
[Music]
it looks like someone might be getting a
little obsessed why are you so obsessed
with me this is the kind of delusional
behavior which can only be exhibited by
people who've evaded accountability or
being beholden to any form of truth
throughout their entire lives that's
long form for professional journalist
so i mean he pulled out some statistics
but what kind of behavior would you
expect from someone who was fired for
reporting fake news and is currently
facing a defamation lawsuit now granted
mr montesmelli is innocent until proven
guilty but he's also been accused of and
admitted to making inappropriate sexual
remarks to random women [ __ ]
that's true but hey we all make
repeatedly the same mistakes right
we all do
i don't know am i just being too harsh
comment below and let mr monicelli know
what you think of his time in the
spotlight
now luckily for the country not everyone
is like mr montecilli over here and in
the final installment of our three-part
series on this topic we'll be able to
get back to the basics of change my mind
with some folks who were happy to take
part sit down have conversations and
honestly made me glad to have done it so
come back monday april 11th to check
that out if you aren't already tuning in
to the daily show at 10 a.m eastern
steven we were actually able to get the
zoom in enhance completed on
monticelli's phone oh really were we
were able to get it we'll bring it in
[Music]
that's jason bourne
hey if you liked this video click one of
these other videos
playing in a box hit the notification
bell or just you know hit the share
button with your friends if you didn't
like it
do all those things as well or um
boycott our sponsors
i'd highly recommend it uh send your
email to crottershop.com where this
shirt is available and dave landau's
shirt ooh
right they should they should boycott
crowder shop and send their email there
they should they should also i will send
them this exact shirt yeah with my smell
on it for an extra 10. also we have a
dna scraper filled with dead skin cells
from dave landau the thing is if you
want to send your complaint and boycott
letter at crowdershop.com
you have to it only you have to buy a
shirt and then you you put it in the
return receipt